hey now  think positively all right  we talked about this  i know we hardly talk about anything  else  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  mother miranda i regret to inform you  that ethan winters has  escaped that fool heisenberg  because he is in my castle and has  already proven too much for my daughters  to handle  when i find him  no mother miranda yes  of course i understand the importance of  the ceremony  i won't let you down  can someone please tell me what the hell  is going on here  no the place is full of nothing but  blood and death  aah  wow well ethan winters  there you are  who the [ __ ] are you  let's see what you're really made of  ethan winters  you